[Música]
despedimos a daniela en economía para
darle paso a los deportes en directo
américa de france 24 y vamos a iniciar
entonces este último bloque deportivo de
la mañana en europa con una jornada del
abierto de tenis de roland garros o luís
méndez en el estudio si es raúl porque
ya se conoce la primera semifinalista de
este torneo y se trata de la italiana
martina tristán quien derrotó en tres
set la canadiense leila fernández con
parciales de 6 2 6 7 y 6 3 pero para
ampliar más sobre esta jornada de roland
garros vamos a parís con nuestra
compañera natalia ruiz ir alto buendía
natalia saludos y buena tarde para usted
qué sensación deje el partido que
clasificó a martina a la semifinal de
este torneo
muy buenas tardes para ustedes pues deja
una sensación un poco de tristeza por
leila fernández quien venía haciendo un
excelente torneo mostrándose bastante
sólida pero hoy definitivamente no
estaba en ese partido y sobre todo se
encontró ante una jugadora italiana que
batalló todo el tiempo que nunca dio por
perdido absolutamente ninguno de los dos
puntos así que creo que ahí está un poco
como la tristeza pero finalmente fue se
necesita eso también una jugadora que
sea bastante bastante luchadora marta
trevisán que pues también como leyla
fernández es zurda también tiene ese
revés a dos manos y fue pues con estas
armas que logró finalmente conseguir su
paso a semifinales por primera vez o la
nata que bueno saludarla nuevamente muy
buena tarde la jornada también está con
mucha atención por lo que puede ser el
duelo entre djokovic y rafael a no
así después de eso no se habla si no se
deje ese duelo el número 59 sobre todo
porque bueno había la cuestión de que
sea un partido de noche ya toni nadal
dijo a la prensa española el día de ayer
que no era unas condiciones que
favorecieran a su sobrino porque digamos
que allí la pelota es menos rápida en
todo caso para rafael nadal su juego
menos claro mientras que para djokovic
esto podría ayudarlo más podría tener
menos dificultades que si jugará contra
rafael nadal de día pero igual sabemos
que el espanyol va a salir absolutamente
con todo tratando de que este no sea su
último partido de roland garros dice que
él no sabe si lo sea en todo caso además
de esto pues en este duelo vamos a tener
va a ser el partido digamos de las
primeras veces será la primera vez que
dos jugadores con más de con 20 títulos
o más en gran slam se enfrenten será la
primera vez en que dos jugadores se
enfrenten con más de 1000 victorias y
también primera vez en que sea estos dos
jugadores que se enfrentan que tienen
más de 300 victorias en el grand slam
así que vamos a ver para rafael nadal
que justamente si no estoy este viernes
cumpleaños natalia y una pregunta más
también con respecto a estos cuartos de
final será el duelo de carlos alcaraz
que tuvo un difícil partido en su última
presentación frente al alexander zverev
el alemán un duelo que también es muy
esperado dentro de la pista parisina
así después estos dos jugadores se han
enfrentado en tres ocasiones y en dos de
ellas ha sido el alemán el que se ha
llevado el se ha llevado las victorias
así que muy esperado también este duelo
pero digamos que ese adiós verdad
tampoco es que haya hecho un gran roland
garros a carlos alcaraz ha tenido sus
problemas sus partidos un poco difíciles
porque como por ejemplo el que tuvo ante
el ramos viñolas pero él ha venido
digamos de menos a más y ese último
partido que jugó ante care and high and
off de rusia pues ahí quedó demostrado
que está cada vez mejor cada vez más
maduro y sobre todo logrando puntos en
los momentos que más lo necesita así que
ese es otro de los de los duelos
importantes del día de hoy y alcaraz que
va a tratar de clasificar a una
semifinal aquí en roland garros y podría
ser el jugador más joven en conseguirlo
desde que rafael nadal lo consiguiera en
el 2005 mientras que serán sellos verdes
pues selva está ya en sus cuartos de
final la cuarta vez por en los últimos
cinco años y vamos a ver entonces si
este triunfo de nadal sería su regla
anticipada de cumpleaños natal es
muchísimas gracias como siempre por toda
la información desde parís hablando del
roland garros nosotros regresamos al
estudio aquí en la ciudad de bogotá luis
méndez porque ya lamentablemente se nos
acabó el tiempo tenemos que despedir en
nuestro programa muchísimas gracias al
experto en información deportiva nos
vemos mañana con más ustedes también
gracias por acompañarnos un día más en
directo américa de france 24 los veo en
minutos en un noticiero habitual de
nuestro canal
[Música]